pressing news as you are aware
dumbledore is a proud member of the lgbt
community
but
as you may not be aware he is not
allowed to be his true self in china did
you see this no
let me tell you about i mean dumbledore
kept coming out
he came out more times than sam smith
so references to a gay relationship were
edited out of fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore by warner brothers
for the film's release in china as a
studio we're committed to safeguarding
the integrity of every film we release
and that extends the circumstances that
necessitate making nuanced cuts in order
to respond sensitively to a variety of
in-market factors warner brothers said
in a statement to variety our hope is to
release the features worldwide as
released by their creators but
historically we have faced small edits
made in local markets
how gay was dumbledore six seconds of
dialogue
what is it like
it's dialogue it's time oh it's dialogue
yeah it's not a full frontal scene come
on it's a film for children but my point
is that uh he said something to this guy
about how i used to love you or
something like that uh and it's been cut
wasn't that now we saw
harry potter on stage in new york with
jordan and tammy peterson only a couple
months ago
and if i remember rightly there was some
very slight illusion to gain us there
yeah the whole thing was homoerotic
i wouldn't agree with you there i i
thought there were lots of it was just
charming but the the no
there was some reference to it
uh didn't because i mean we don't know
we i know this is potterology but i
thought
jk rowling only said that dumbledore was
gay laughed the whole franchise had been
in 2009
she posthumously brought stomachs
of it
and yeah so richard harry's who died had
no idea he was playing a gay character
no which would have probably influenced
the role massively changed uh yeah the
point just being that
hollywood yeah hollywood to florida is
we say gay yeah yeah but hollywood to
china is we'll say whatever you want
please take our money beautiful isn't it
yeah it's beautiful well i mean i've i
just have unending contempt for these
people as you probably guessed
and uh the contempt is based on a lot of
things but one is the way in which these
sorts of
entertainment honchos and so on always
they just their idea of bravery is
poking at empty hornets nests and
whenever they find a real hornet's nest
they just run a million miles
and that's why they're perfectly willing
to weirdly melt down
over florida and to santa's and
a bill which is totally reasonable in my
view
to
not like tell three-year-olds
that they might wake up the next morning
in a different sex that's
i don't think there's anything wrong
with
not teaching kindergarteners crazy
hundred gender two-spirit ideology which
was come up with about yesterday and
which they're still trying to work on to
make make any sense at all which it
never will
it's just completely typical the same
people who have a meltdown about that
happening
and attack florida
uh will be totally silent when the
communist party china expects different
rules
that's uh that's one of the ways in
which the 21st century could go
you know
there's of course of course we don't
update you sir
did you see that a trans author wrote a
horror novel in which jk rowling is
burned alive by a trans woman
i didn't but you're missing out on
everything i haven't even read that book
no it sounds like nobody has i don't
know i don't know anymore i don't know
if it's yet to come out but what i do
know is that the secrets of dumbledore
had a 9.7 million dollar
first weekend in china which meant that
two out of every three people at the
cinema
was going to see
that film in china just tighten this in
a little bit
that's
that's uh
well
the rules are different there aren't
they and the cynical corporations
realize that
and uh
either none of it surprises me at all
um
this is how hollywood and other
companies operate
as i say they they pretend to be very
very brave they give each other rewards
for bravery they they meet up and slap
each other on the back for bravery they
talk about human rights in florida and
lots of things like that and then they
um just of course they do this in china
it's like ricky gervais said in the
golden globes the other the other year
you know is if isis set up a streaming
service these people would run to it you
know i mean of course they would they'd
work for it if the cash came in i mean
uh look at all these companies apple
they're all such
damn cynics they all know how to play
this sort of virtue signaling thing in
america and totally different rules
abroad it's always been like that it's
always been like that
um but i i am slightly amused by this
meltdown about the texas thing did you
see james saki the other day she cried
she cried
she said i'm just become very emotional
about what's happening in florida
because people are mean
well i mean
i don't know i mean i maybe she's just
trying to make sure her job at msnbc is
secure
uh because if you express that amount of
sentimentality and stupidity then
you're almost certain to keep a job at
msnbc she could have got a golden globe
for the performance it was do you think
she believes it i don't know i think if
you wind themselves up about this stuff
they wind themselves up about issues
that are
that are
just not relevant
the line between persona performance and
identity kind of begins to get blurred i
mean
obviously the white house spokesperson
is obviously she's a smart woman
she must know that the florida bill in
question doesn't say what she's
pretending it says isn't gonna do what
she's pretending it'll do she must know
that i mean she's not stupid very stupid
people who aren't informed might believe
that that actually governor ron desantis
has decided that you're not allowed to
say the word gay in florida
but you i don't believe that somebody's
well informed could think that so they
they they whip themselves up on on
things that don't hurt them you know
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace